bonsoir à mourad gazier merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france le
service fédéral de sécurité russe qui
publie donc des images qui montrent
clairement une réunion secrète entre
l'un des associés les plus proches de
nouvelles ni et un officier du
renseignement britannique qui aurait eu
lieu il ya quelques temps
pouvez vous nous en dire plus sur cette
rencontre présumée mansion 2 6 pouces
lorsque le second secrétaire aux
affaires politiques de l'ambassade du
régime ont aussi un rencontre dans un
restaurant moscovite chacun mains de
l'opposition vladimir à chaud peuvent le
bras droit d'alexei la vanille à
chocques of veut maintenant au royaume
uni et 8 ans il prend toujours pas à un
mouvement de l'opposition en russie
[Musique]
maintenant que nous avons vu cette vidéo
il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes concernant
les relations entre le royaume uni et
l'opposition russe des relations qui
pourraient être du bien plus forte qu'on
ne le pensait auparavant
car si l'on écoute les peintures ajoute
cette vidéo
monsieur h au café semble sous-entendre
qu'ils ont besoin de financements
supplémentaires
et pourquoi ces images n'ont plus
d'argent nous agrandir y ont bien sûr le
traiteur
un peu d'argent si quelqu'un dépensé je
ne sais pas à 10 20 millions de dollars
par an pour soutenir cela nous verrions
les choses différemment
et ce n'est pas une grosse somme
d'argent pour des gens qui ont des
milliards un jeu c'est donc le message
que j'essaie de faire passer dans le
cadre de ma campagne de collecte de
feuilles notamment parlons aujourd'hui
monde des affaires et ses terres voilà
on vient donc de voir cette vidéo
pourquoi ces images sont-elles diffusé
maintenant il semble si elle pense que
ceux qui finançait l'opposition
pourrions-nous pourrait récupérer des
milliards à l'habitude vous pourriez
récupérer des milliards une fois que
l'opposition serait au pouvoir ne
spécifie pas à quelle somme mais en tout
cas bien plus que cet argent quand il
parle il évoque l'idée d'empêcher les
entreprises russes par exemple de faire
des affaires en europe
il explique comment il envisageait
d'arriver au pouvoir en organisant des
pros des manifestations de masse il
parle de propagande
également il parle de propagande contre
la guerre plus tôt comptines donc
beaucoup de questions sont suscitées par
à cette vidéo alors selon le fsb la
grande bretagne et est étroitement lié à
l'opposition russe et fournit un soutien
financier et des renseignements à ses
membres quels sont les éléments qui
accréditent cette thèse en position
figure regardez le nombre des figures de
l'opposition s'ils vivent au royaume uni
enseignement un cadre du colloque de la
fondation d'avec cnra ni à trouver
l'asile
l'étiquette beaucoup d'autres membres de
cette organisation se trouve au
royaume-uni et cela est à ton histoire
vous vous connaissez par exemple ne
s'inscrit pas là qui avait été condamné
pour traîtrise qui avait transféré d
organisation secrète alors qu'il
travaillait pour la russie à horoya lui
eh bien il a été transféré au royaume
uni et là bas il a également reçu un
permis de résidence
donc il ya une longue histoire de
relations entre le royaume et les
opposants politiques russes mais j'ai
commencé mon cas si en rappelant l
histoire qui remonte à 2006 le second
secrétaire aux affaires politiques de
l'ambassade du royaume uni matou à
l'époque s'est retrouvé impliqué dans un
scandale en scandale autour d'une fausse
pierre qui était utilisé comme appareil
de communication secret donc il y a une
histoire d'espionnage britannique en
russie et en 2019 il y avait un projet
une initiative integrity ce projet était
financé par le royaume uni est soutenu
par le royaume uni qui rassemblait des
journalistes
avec un programme anti russe en 2019 il
ya eu des fuites de documents montrant
que le gouvernement britannique avait
versé 20 mille livres à des alliés
de nava libyen que ses alliés en
question est niée donc il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'éléments qui indiquent des
liens entre la les services de
renseignement britanniques et les
activités de l'opposition russe
beaucoup de questions aussi quels
seraient les intérêts de la grande
bretagne a aidé le canada ni la question
est très simple
quel serait l'intérêt de quiconque à
avoir des amis à la tête d'un autre pays
si cela a causé beaucoup de remous
ce scandale notamment parce que si
l'opposition travail
effectivement même si cela n'a pas été
complètement prouvé avec le royaume uni
et bien c'est grave
il faut savoir que le royaume uni a
refusé de commenter cette vidéo disant
qu'il refuse de commenter les fuites
donc voilà une vidéo où des membres de
l'opposition et 10 ha à une personne que
le fsb considère comme un agent du mi6
disant nous allons vous donner des
informations permettant de bannir des
entreprises telles que la seconde plus
importante banque russe de l'europe et
cela vous va vous aider parce que les
tanks britanniques tels que love to
barre qu'ils auront moins de concurrence
pouvez vous imaginer par exemple à
socialiste du parti socialiste français
le vice président par exemple du parti
socialiste
captés dans une vidéo en train de
discuter avec un agent du renseignement
chinois lui expliquant comment ils
travaillent afin que les entreprises
françaises ne puisse plus travailler en
chine afin que les entreprises chinoises
et moins de concurrents
c'est exactement la situation dont nous
parlons à jour cov face caméra cynique
il a présenté de preuves gouvernement
britannique que des entreprises
britanniques des entreprises russes
devraient être interdits de travailler
en europe et en rajoutant cela serait
une bonne chose pour vous donc cela a
causé cela causerait un tollé en france
cela serait la fin de la carrière
politique qu'il avait personne la
question voici pourquoi
7 cette information a causé beaucoup de
romans en russie pourquoi cela suscite
beaucoup de conversation et à juste
titre il pourrait s'agir d'un risque
pour la sécurité de la russie
question magazine fabi non à ce que
d'autres agences de renseignement
pourrait être en lien avec le clan
n'avaient ni pourrez pas vous le dire je
n'ai pas accès aux banques de tonner des
renseignements russes
je ne je n'ai pas toutes les
informations dont le fsb dispose
cela fait huit ans qu'ils ont cette
vidéo et beaucoup de russes ailleurs
demande mais pourquoi cette vidéo ne
scelle pas était diffusée plus tôt quoi
avez vous attendu 8 9 ans pourquoi la
publier maintenant c'est d'intérêt
public de savoir que des citoyens
russ discute avec les renseignements
britanniques afin que les citoyens
sachent pour qu'ils votent mais
l'espionnage c'est l'espionnage cela ne
nous fait pas cela remonte à longtemps
et cela va continuer longtemps
différents états différents critères de
sécurité et certains critères le
portrait validé que si l'on sait ce que
font les autres pays les relations de la
russie avec d'autres et elles ne sont
pas très bonnes donc ce serait logique
que la france par exemple finances une
opposition qui il aurait plus amicales
les etats unis ont traversé quatre ans
de crise parce que l'on croyait il n'y a
pas de vidéo ou de documents montrant
donald trump discutant avec des
diplomates russes ne s'agissait que de
rumeurs et pourtant les états unis ont
passé quatre ans en prison parce qu'on
soupçonnait que donald trump avait des
liens avec des connivences avec le
kremlin avec le renseignement russe
donc c'est un sujet de préoccupation
majeur et je certain que beaucoup
d'agents de renseignement dans le monde
ont des liens non seulement avec
l'opposition russe mais également avec
le gouvernement russe c'est la façon
dont ça marche
merci murad agha ziem jordanie ferté
internationale d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france